[Music]
Prince George is going to have an
important role that his grandfather King
Charles's coronation don't forget this
is all part of the training for Prince
George who will one day be king
Buckingham Palace says Prince William
and Kate Middleton's eldest son will
serve as a page of Honor on his
Grandpa's big day May 6th and he'll be
joined by several of Queen Camilla's
grandchildren like Prince Charles when
he was that much younger just four
watched his mother crowned this will be
Prince George watching his grandfather
ground with his father looking onto
knowing that he will be next Kensington
Palace spokesperson tells E.T they're
all very excited about Prince George's
role and it'll be an incredibly special
moment but he's not alone his siblings
princess Charlotte and Prince Louis will
be part of the special day too she
behaved so impeccably on the day of the
Queen's funeral who've shown that they
are absolutely able to behave according
to a situation even one as formal as
this a royal Insider tells E.T Kaden
Williams kiddos will have a high profile
role on Coronation Day here's the
breakdown young Royals will accompany
their parents in a carriage following
the Golden State Carriage then they'll
join them on the balcony of Buckingham
Palace familiar to this moment however
only George and Charlotte will go to the
coronation inside Westminster Abbey with
William and Kate in the same way that
William always had his wingman in Harry
I think it's rather wonderful that that
is being echoed here with George and
Charlotte you know you're going to see I
think real teamwork at place here as for
the little bro Louie that's still TBD
our source says The Prince and Princess
of Wales will make a decision about
their four-year-old attending the
service closer to date the weight could
have something to do with the prince's
Antics at past Royal events
last year he stole the spotlight while
making silly faces at the trooping the
color ceremony
then at the Queen's Platinum Jubilee
pageant he got caught teasing his mama
[Music]
but back to Coronation Day the entire
Wales family will be there but as for
William's brother Prince Harry and his
wife Meghan Markle that's also TBD it is
his son after all and the King really
does want a Reconciliation in the long
term in February A source told E.T
Charles very much once the couple and
his family at the coronation and the
Duke and Duchess did receive an invite
but whether they'll attend will remain
to be seen if they do their appearance
could overshadow the coronation itself
given the current family tension The
Source tells E.T no one wants to see the
focus taken away from King Charles
adding the fear is if they do come more
private matters could be made public so
efforts are being made to prevent that
for the run-up to the coronation to be
overshadowed by these Headlines by Harry
and Megan in this Royal rival Court over
in America is problematic so really a
Reconciliation is going to be in the
best interest of the firm whether that's
a real and meaningful and long-lasting
well that's the million dollar question
can that actually happen
[Music]